kendall Jenner reveals the one thing
she'd do if she weren't famous for a day
it's not always easy 22 year old
supermodel chats with her pal Cara
Delevingne
inside Harper bazaars February issue and
gets candid about growing up in the
public eye quote I had a pretty normal
childhood with a twist she added quote I
can't really complain except for now
maybe I would like to go to Disneyland
or a public beach to go to a beach in
peace would be lovely to be able to not
be bothered would be awesome I'm not
gonna like let the paparazzi like stop
me from doing that and living my life
and just being a normal person Jenner
also opened up about her debilitating
anxiety I'm freaking out quote I
literally wake up in the middle of the
night with full-on panic attacks you go
online and you see everyone saying the
worst things to each other and it's hard
to stay positive but in a video for the
mag she reveals how she's finding peace
I just learned how to meditate properly
so I've been doing that a lot it's a
peaceful
you
[Music]